there you go and step cross under push
cross under hold it
back in the rink
this time with a dancing on ice star by
his side what about another jump souh
cow since our report in may the ice
skating community rallied to help
seven-year-old gorsha unable to go home
as the war in ukraine continues
seeing and hearing his story just really
pulled out my heartstrings
i think as a professional skater
in the likes of working with 15
different celebrities that i have with
dancing on ice we can spot certain
things that a normal coach or
a normal skater may not see
and seeing the tapes of him and from
when you guys filmed him i definitely
can tell that he has potential is it's
just even the way that he stands in his
skates i can just tell that he's got it
he's going to be he's a talented kid
back home gorsha would get up at five in
the morning six days a week to train but
all that stopped when he fled the
conflict
outside outside
as well as help from matt coaches from
his new local rink planet ice in bristol
are also providing training
i've been giving him strong lessons
getting him to stretch his legs and
stretch his arms and look up so he
doesn't look down on the ice bring out
his really lovely confidence that he has
he's a very brave little boy to have
gone through what he has
and we just want to support him any way
we can
gorsha and his mum arena are living with
a host family in bristol they've been
overwhelmed by the help they've received
since the last filming we met a lot of
amazing people i'm sure he is now more
confident
he has a lot of instructions he goes to
the ice
he received the new skates
and
his sketching is now more smooth so
he's stronger now
five
six
seven
gorsha and his mom hope to get home as
soon as possible but until then he's
getting help from some of the best in
the business
i will definitely keep an eye on his
journey and who knows maybe in a couple
years he'll be on dancing eyes
never know
stretch stretch stretch stretch stretch
stretch dan white is sky news in bristol